Climbing is a popular hobby among adrenaline junkies.
The tower called the Excalibur is the world's tallest climbing wall.
Located in Groningen, The Netherlands, the vertical structure stands 121 feet high.
However, the most notable aspect is a bend in the design.
From a distance, it appears as though the tower is tipping over.
The curve tips 36 feet away from the base, serving as an overhang.
That aspect replicates the grueling twists of climbing a real peak.
The freestanding Excalibur was built in 2004 at a climb center.
An employee at the facility stated, "The wall offers a unique experience...
...for anyone interested in climbing and doesn't want to travel too far.
The routes are of varying difficulty so beginners can climb on it, too.
But don't expect to reach the top on your very first time."
The outdoor tower is strategically set among the flat, picturesque countryside,...
...which means adventure seekers can take in the beautiful views while scaling the structure.